robert shapiro began his entertainment
career in the mailroom of the William
Morris Agency rising to become managing
director of their London office
eventually heading their international
motion picture department he then became
president of Warner Brothers worldwide
theatrical production division he has
produced over a dozen film and
television shows including pee-wee's big
adventure Empire of the Sun and black
beauty presenting the award to scissor
Vittal is Robert Shapiro
[Applause]
thank you
good evening Alfred Hitchcock said to
make a great film you need three things
the screenplay the screenplay the
screenplay he was absolutely correct
after all that's why we're here tonight
to usher in the latest class of Nicholl
fellowship screenwriters the engaging
and wonderfully original screenplay the
great nothing is far from nothing for me
it is among other things the great
surprise I'm always excited when a
screenwriter surprises me with a feeling
caused by something unexpected and
unusual as Cesare Vitali has done with
his screenplay Cesare has what we all
hope to discover in a writer especially
a screenwriter a unique voice says I was
born and raised in Brazil
although Portuguese was his primary
language he learned English by watching
American films and television he was
educated in Brazil and the United States
and was inspired by one of his favorite
films children of men and the writings
of Cormac McCarthy I can't wait to read
what says our creates next and I'm
confident that he'll continue to
entertain and surprise I believe too
that it's a possibility that tonight is
the first of many times that he will say
the words I'd like to thank the Academy
ladies and gentlemen it is my great
pleasure to introduce to you the
extremely talented screenwriter of the
great nothing and freshly minted nickel
fellow Cesare Vitaly
[Applause]
picture with everything thank you thank
you you guys video you're right this is
terrifying just could you look okay
first and foremost I'd like to thank the
Academy and also the new co committee
thank you so much for believing in me
this this has been amazing I'd also like
to thank my managers Jennifer and Jen
and my agents Teddy and Adam for
standing by my side to this journey
every step of the way
and my first screenwriting professor
Phillip Eisner for helping me take the
very first step I'd also like to thank
my family my cousin Fernanda who's here
tonight oh okay she's from ok my brother
and my two sisters and my father and
mother who always believed in me even
when I didn't mom dad thank you so much
for everything this is your victory
okay I also like to thank someone else
is here tonight and that's my best
friend half a Ella hi there
when she heard that guy won she bought a
four-day roundtrip ticket from Brazil
and those are not those are not cheap
when you buy it just a second just to be
here for no other reason than the fact
that she's the greatest person I know
and she's the best friend a person can
have I also I promise you that here to
Disneyland tomorrow so there's that but
I think it was mostly because she likes
me I hope and finally I like to share
this with my fellow writers were also
being recognized tonight and with every
other writer out there in the world
putting a lego symbol she get on page
and hoping to get them in just the right
order my script is about two people who
had their lives turned upside down by
events they could not control and life
can be so much like that sometimes
chaotic unpredictable and terrifyingly
random but there's one thing we can't
control and that's the stories we tell
one another so never stop writing thank
you very much
[Applause]